Are your hands and feet always cold?
Be careful!
The most dangerous type of cold hands and feet
That is
The blood flow may be blocked.
Even stroke
Or it could be a precursor to a myocardial infarction.
You often tap the 'shí xuān xué (transliteration) acupoint.'
Blood circulation
When things are going smoothly
Your hands will feel warm.
It also lowers blood pressure
It has the effect of preventing dizziness.
Hu Naiwen is about to begin his lecture.
I am your old friend, Dr. Hu.
Your hands and feet are always cold in winter.
Be careful!
The most dangerous type of cold hands and feet
That is, one side of the hand
One foot is cold
When you find that only one side of your hand or foot
is consistently cold,
numb, and weak
We cannot be negligent
It's possible that the blood flow is blocked.
Even a precursor to stroke
or myocardial infarction
Don't delay, go see a doctor immediately.
check it for you
These three types of people especially need to be careful.
Over 50 years old
People with diabetes
Cardiovascular disease
hands and feet are always cold
It might be a problem with blood circulation.
Over time,
this can also lead to numbness
n the hands
and feet and slow wound healing
even
Stroke or
myocardial infarction
that having cold hands and feet was so serious
I didn't know
What causes cold hands and feet?
What kind of constitution causes cold hands and feet?
There are two reasons
The first is a constitution that is prone to coldness.
It's when you feel the wind
just felt
It's cold.
The second is insufficient blood or anemia.
Traditional Chinese medicine calls this blood deficiency.
It's just that face was pale
limbs are cold
How to improve cold hands and feet?
tell you right away
Tap your hands 30 times in the morning and evening
Warm hands, warm feet, lower blood pressure
When hands and feet are cold
Except for putting your hand
into the other half's pocket
I'll teach you a method
that's effective and requires no help
That is tapping the shí xuān xué (transliteration) acupoints.
You often tap the shí xuān xué (transliteration)acupoint
When blood circulation is smooth
Your hands will feel warm
It also has
Lowering blood pressure and preventing dizziness
Where are the shí xuān xué (transliteration)acupoints?
At the fingertip
It is the front of the tips of all ten fingers.
It is called the shí xuān xué (transliteration)acupoints
These places are furthest from the heart
Blood circulation
is most prone to getting stuck
I know, I know
Is it tapped like this?
That's how it is with my beautiful wife
She's there every day, banging and tapping.
You can tap like this at home by yourself
Your hands, palms facing each other
Fingers bent
The fingertips of the left and right hands are like this.
thump thump thump
Knock it 30 times
Divided into morning and evening
Tapping each one about 15 times should be enough.
Not much Tappingis needed
There is another way to Tapping
accelerates blood circulation.
It's with your other half.
tapping with your beautiful wife
Just like that, tapping
Just tappinglike that
OK
My hands were ice cold just now
but tapping them
warms them up
That's awesome!
The shí xuān xué (transliteration)acupointsare
The place where blood and qi converge at the ten fingers
It can help you regulate Yin and Yang and kāi qiào (transliteration)
Able to refresh the mind
Clinically
I can use the shí xuān xué (transliteration)acupointsfor emergency treatment.
People in a coma after a stroke
Helps redistribute blood
I once had a patient
I saw this patient in the hospital.
The patient in the other bed surprisingly
The phenomenon of a stroke has appeared
His wife told me
Can you come and take a look?
I saw a stroke
I immediately bled a little blood
from that spot
It recovered immediately
Three parts of the body should not be exposed to cold.
Tapping one spot on the leg can dispel cold and prevent hair loss.
It's getting cold.
People with partners
The happiest thing
is having someone tuck you in
People without a partner
We should also make sure
we are dressed warmly
and appropriately
Love yourself more
Someone has boyfriend energy
I have warmth
wearing a lot of clothes
Why does body always feel cold?
Please check these three places.
Is it wrapped up tightly?
First foot sole
Second neck
Third abdomen
The soles of your feet are the first part of your body that needs to be kept warm.
A lady who likes to wear short socks and short skirts
and loves to show off her beautiful legs
Did you know?
Our feet
It is the source of all the body's yang energy.
expose its legs
The cold wind blew directly into the body.
Yang energy dissipates rapidly
At this time
What problems might occur?
Hán xié (transliteration) enter through the feet
It invaded from the legs.
This leads to cold hands and feet
Poor blood circulation
It may also cause
joint pain
Joint pain
In youth, one prioritizes appearance
in old age, this leads to joint pain.
That's not worth it
You should choose a pair of warm pants. And socks?
Choose a pair of thick socks
From the ankle to the calf
Both can keep you warm and retain your Yang energy.
I'll also teach you
how to tap your kidney meridian later
The second is the neck.
There is a fēng chí (transliteration) acupoint and a fēng fǔ (transliteration) acupoint on the neck.
These places?
That's where the wind can most easily get in.
So went inside.
That wind, that cold
Blood pressure spiked immediately
You can wear a scarf.
To block the cold
Third is the abdomen.
It's too cold
Did you know?
The sympathetic nerve will affect the stomach and intestines.
Causes peristalsis problems
It makes you prone to diarrhea
Girls are prone to menstrual cramps
When we go out
At times like this
You have to put your neck
Wrap the scarf
The belly
should not be exposed
Don't let people see it
not that shouldn't look.
should wear thick socks
Yes, I'll teach you a way
to warm up your feet
It's about patting the kidney meridian.
It can improve circulation
Warm up
aIt can also prevent hair loss.
The kidney meridian runs near the ankle.
This place
There are three very important acupoints
Fù liū (transliteration) acupoints, zhào hǎi (transliteration) acupoints, tài xī (transliteration) acupoints
How to tapping?
You clench your fist
From top to bottom at Fù liū (transliteration) acupoints
This is how you tap the zhào hǎi (transliteration) acupoints
Then what
Then from bottom to top
Tap the tài xī (transliteration) acupoints
tapping, tapping, tapping, just like that.
It's enough to go back
and forth three to five times a day
First, find the Fù liū (transliteration) acupoints
It is on the inside of the lower leg.
Two cun above the inner ankle tip
A little in front of the Achilles tendon in the foot
Fù liū (transliteration) acupoints can unblock meridians and reduce edema.
People with joint problems
and prone to edema
You can often be here
Press and tap.
Then find the tài xī (transliteration) acupoints
tài xī (transliteration) acupoints
It is behind the medial malleolus.
A recessed area
It's an important acupoint for tonifying the kidneys.
The vital energy of the Kidney Meridian resides in this place.
You are someone who experiences cold hands and feet
and lower back and knee pain
They often tap the tài xī (transliteration) acupoints
It can protect this kidney
Finally, zhào hǎi (transliteration) acupoints
zhào hǎi (transliteration) acupoints
It is below the medial malleolus.
The slight indentation at the front
Tapping it can improve forgetfulness
Insomnia, dry hair
It can also make you less afraid of the cold.
So when is the best time to tap it?
When the kidney meridian is at its peak
The peak time was
5 p.m. to 7 p.m.
From 5 pm to 7 pm
Between 7 and 9 o'clock
can also come and get some nourishment again
Those who go to work
Tap it during lunchtime
Is this okay?
Of course you can!
Why not?
That is, when I speak Taiwanese
that is
If you tapping, you'll be benefits
It's not abenefits
That is
If you tapping, you'll be benefits
If you tappingon it, you'll be benefits
feet are still cold even with thick socks on.
One sheet of paper can quickly warm up your feet.
People who are afraid of the cold wear wool socks.
feet are cold again
What to do if I can't sleep at night?
How can warm feet?
I'm telling you
There is a way to save money
You just need to put a piece of paper
Put it inside the shoe
That will warm up your feet.
What kind of paper is so amazing?
It's aluminum foil.
Can aluminum foil keep warm?
Can
Take a piece of aluminum foil.
Place the shiny side up
Covering the front of the foot
Wear slippers again
The soles of feet can heat up instantly
It is said that when wearing shoes
It can heat up
to 8 degrees
Why
Because of the glossy surface of aluminum foil
Excellent thermal conductivity
It can warm your heels
It quickly spread to the toes
This is a famous Japanese naturopathic doctor.
His name is Kawashima Akira, and his experiments...
He is a medical doctor specializing in the study of cold-sensitive constitution
You can try it before bed tonight.
Do you have any other tips for keeping warm?
Leave a message and share with us
Let's keep each other warm
5 Foods That Cause Heat
Hands and feet are warm to the touch
What should I eat to improve cold hands and feet?
As we mentioned earlier
People with blood deficiency who have cold hands and feet
You can eat five kinds of food
Lamb, red dates, cinnamon, ginger, chives
Come, let me teach you how to eat.
Let's start with lamb.
The best way to eat it is...
I know
Angelica root, ginger, and lamb soup
Is it right or wrong?
Of course it's right.
The answer is absolutely yes.
You cook for your parents, husband, and children.
One bowl each
Eating mutton can replenish muscle strength.
Angelica sinensis nourishes blood, while ginger invigorates blood circulation.
body felt warm afte
Promote blood circulation
You should also remember to have a bowl yourself!
Boost your family's immunity together
Make your cheeks glow with rosy blood.
Angelica root, ginger, and lamb soup
Suitable for both medicinal and edible purposes
Kān chēng yào wù zhī jīng (transliteration)
The ancestor of medical prescriptions
Have you had this experience?
In winter
Because the cold wind blew into stomach.
This resulted in severe abdominal pain.
There is a legendary figure in our traditional Chinese medicine community.
His name is zhāng zhòng jǐng (transliteration)
Known as the Sage of Medicine
He used Angelica root, ginger, and lamb soup
Give it to people with this problem
Let individuals with this condition take it
The patient only took it twice.
stomach pain is gone
body is warm
The effect is amazing!
The second one is red dates.
Light menstrual flow
Cold hands and feet
Sisters who get tired easily
What can drink?
You can make a cup
Red date and ginger tea
Or red date and longan tea
Red dates can replenish blood and qi.
It will gradually dissipate
that weak,
chilly feeling in you
Blood circulation becomes smoother
Third is ginger
When you are stir-frying vegetables, making soup, etc.
Adding a little ginger is just right.
Ginger can promote blood circulation andsàn hán (transliteration)
You can also order a curry rice when eating out
The curry also contains turmeric
It can warm the body and reduce inflammation.
The fourth is cinnamon.
Cinnamon is amazing!
What are its amazing effects?
It means yǐn shèn qì guī yú yuán (transliteration)
That is, it goes into the kidneys.
What does that mean?
It's about protecting kidney qi so it doesn't dissipate.
Enhance the feeling of warmth throughout the body
People with cold constitution
hands and feet will feel warm after eating it
The fifth is Chinese chives
There's a saying: "Onions in January, chives in February."
In the second month of the lunar calendar
Eating leeks is the best way to nourish the kidneys.
Bring the yang energy all the way to your hands and feet
Improve cold sensitivity constitution
Okay, I'm going to the market in a bit.
Buy all these vegetables